Kendra and her husband and their two kids moved back to Boston, and it wasn't going great for her. She's a teacher but hadn't found a teaching job yet, so she did odd jobs-- a little thing at the John F. Kennedy Presidential Library. She worked as an usher for the Boston Symphony Orchestra, which-- can I say-- these are like the kind of Boston-specific jobs you would give a character who moved to Boston in a bad movie.
Kendra和她的丈夫以及两个孩子搬回了波士顿，但她的生活并不顺心。她是一名教师，却一直没找到教职，所以只能做些零工——在约翰·肯尼迪总统图书馆做点琐事。她还在波士顿交响乐团担任领位员，这些工作简直就像是烂俗电影里编剧给那些刚搬到波士顿的角色安排的典型职业。
Like, the only thing I wasn't doing is, like, selling foam "fingahs" at Fenway "Pahk."
我唯一没做过的事，就是在那里的“芬威公园”卖泡沫海绵手指玩具。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And I made, like, very little money.
而且我赚的钱非常少。
She was actually pretty depressed, just dragging herself through the motions of living, not looking forward to anything. And it wouldn't go away. She couldn't shake it.
她当时其实相当沮丧，整个人行尸走肉般地生活，对任何事都提不起劲。这种状态一直挥之不去，她怎么也摆脱不掉。
I would wake up in the morning and feel sort of irritated, like, oh, this again? I went to work, and I would have put a smile on my face, but I oftentimes would not hear anything anyone said to me.
我每天早上醒来都会感到一阵烦躁，心想：噢，又来了？我去上班，脸上强撑着笑容，但通常根本听不清别人对我说了什么。
So she's four months into this new downer of a life, and she gets off work. And it's April, one of the first bright, sunny days after a long, dark winter. And she's excited to take her dog Schuyler to Wollaston Beach near her house on this pretty day. Wollaston's good for a dog, she says, because she's big and kind of a maniac.
就这样浑浑噩噩过了四个月，有一天她下班回家。那是四月的一个日子，经历了漫长阴冷的冬天后，迎来了第一个明媚阳光的午后。她很兴奋，想带着她的狗Schuyler去家附近的沃拉斯顿海滩（Wollaston Beach）走走。她说，那个海滩很适合带狗，因为Schuyler体型大，而且疯起来像个狂人。
And so this beach is perfect because, really, no one was out. We started walking. I let her off leash, because she really wanted to splash around. And she was just frolicking. And I saw her moving closer to the water, and I realized my feet were starting to sink.
那个海滩非常完美，因为根本没人。我们开始散步。我解开了它的牵引绳，因为它很想去戏水。它当时在那儿欢快地蹦跳。我看着它靠近水边，突然意识到我的脚开始往下陷。
Wait, wait. What do you mean "sink"?
等等，等等。你说“下陷”是什么意思？
Sure. So my one foot started to really sink, and then I was attempting to pull that foot out, and then my other foot started to sink. And I realized I was not hitting a hard bottom.
确实是陷下去了。我的一只脚开始猛地往下沉，我试图把那只脚拔出来，结果另一只脚也开始往下陷。我意识到下面根本没有硬实的地基。
So there was no one to call or cry. And it was really happening fast. I was really sinking quite fast. And I should note, Ira, like, I'm not a tall woman. I'm a 4 foot 10" woman. So for me to start sinking, like-- (LAUGHING) I was, like, practically up to my thighs in this muddy, sandy, watery mixture very quickly.
周围没有人可以呼救或哭喊。而且下陷速度极快。我得强调一下，伊拉（Ira），我不高，只有4英尺10英寸（约1.47米）。所以对我来说，下陷简直……（笑）几乎转瞬间，这片淤泥、沙子和水的混合物就已经没过我的大腿了。
Very quickly, like how quick?
非常快，到底有多快？
I would say maybe the whole, like, gravitational pull down into the sand was 30 seconds. It could have been three minutes, for all I know, because time just slowed down.
我觉得整个被重力拖入沙中的过程也就30秒左右。或者也可能是三分钟，谁知道呢，当时感觉时间变慢了。
As she struggled to yank her feet up, she realized the mud and sand and water formed a kind of seal around her boot, holding it down, making it too heavy to lift. And so scary, right? She thought to herself, am I about to break a bone, pulling my leg out? Am I trapped? Am I just going to keep sinking?
当她挣扎着想拔出双脚时，她发现泥沙和水在靴子周围形成了一种真空密封，死死吸住靴子，让它变得异常沉重，根本抬不动。那种感觉很可怕，对吧？她心里想：我拔腿的时候会不会把骨头弄断？我是不是被困住了？我会不会就这样一直陷下去？
I had no idea what to be afraid of. I just know that I was very afraid.
我不知道该害怕什么，我只知道我非常害怕。
Did you think that you could sink all the way under and just go all the way down?
你当时以为自己会彻底陷进去，一直沉到底吗？
Oh, yes. That's 100% where I thought I was headed.
噢，是的。我百分之百确定自己会那样。
Quicksand, she thought. I'm in quicksand-- in Massachusetts. And I thought this was interesting. Apparently, when you find yourself sinking in quicksand, not on a tropical island or a jungle, not when you're poking around some ancient ruins, raiding the lost tombs of dead pharaohs in an old movie, but when it happens just like a 10-minute drive from your own house on a beach in Quincy, Massachusetts, nine minutes from one Dunkin' Donuts and eight minutes from another, the thought that inevitably goes through your head in that situation is, seriously?
流沙，她想。我居然在马萨诸塞州陷入了流沙。我觉得这点很有意思。显然，当你发现自己陷入流沙时，不是在热带岛屿或丛林里，也不是在老电影里探索古文明遗迹、劫掠法老墓穴，而是在离自己家只有10分钟车程、距离两家Dunkin' Donuts甜甜圈店分别只有八九分钟路程的马萨诸塞州昆西市（Quincy），你脑子里不可避免闪过的念头竟然是：认真的吗？
I said, this is bullshit. This is New England. Like, you're telling me that-- like, quicksand? Like, that's something out of Princess Bride. What is it doing at Wollaston Beach? And why aren't there signs to warn me about this?
我说，这太扯了。这是新英格兰啊。你是说……流沙？那是电影《公主新娘》里才有的东西。它怎么会出现在沃拉斯顿海滩？为什么连个警示牌都没有？
Yeah. There's a bit that John Mulaney does-- the comedian John Mulaney-- that when I saw it, I felt like he was saying out loud something that I have always felt. He said that, based on what he saw on TV as a kid, he thought quicksand was going to be a much bigger part of his adulthood than it actually turned out to be.
是啊。喜剧演员约翰·穆兰尼（John Mulaney）有个段子，我看到的时候觉得他简直说出了我一直以来的心声。他说，根据他小时候看电视留下的印象，他以为流沙会成为他成年生活中非常重要的一部分，结果根本不是那么回事。
Because if you watch cartoons, quicksand is the third-biggest thing you have to worry about in adult life, behind real sticks of dynamite and giant anvils falling on you from the sky. Now I've gotten older, not only have I never stepped in quicksand, I've never even heard about it.
因为如果你看卡通片，流沙是你成年后需要担心的第三大威胁，排在“真正的炸药棒”和“从天而降的巨大铁砧”之后。现在我长大了，别说踩进流沙，我甚至连听说都没听说过。
I also was thinking about John Mulaney.
我也想到了约翰·穆兰尼。
You knew that bit?
你也知道那个段子？
Oh, John Mulaney is-- he's on heavy rotation with my kids and me. And I remember thinking, eat your heart out, John Mulaney. If you could see me now.
噢，约翰·穆兰尼的节目我和孩子们经常反复观看。我当时心想：嫉妒去吧，约翰·穆兰尼。要是你能看见我现在这副德行就好了。
OK, so here she was, first up to our ankles, then her knees, now up to her thighs, and still sinking. Her cell phone was in the car. The beach was deserted, except for her dog, who was romping around happily like a goddamn idiot. No one to save her or help out.
好了，当时她先是没过脚踝，接着是膝盖，现在到了大腿，而且还在下陷。她的手机在车里。海滩上空无一人，除了她的狗，它还在那儿像个傻子一样欢快地嬉戏。没有人能来救她或帮她一把。
And then this thing happened. Kendra says she's somebody who usually has a hard time expressing it when she's angry. She's somebody who cries rather than yells. But now, this wave of pure rage shot through her-- rage and outrage just erupting.
就在这时，奇迹发生了。Kendra说她平时是一个很难表达愤怒的人。比起大吼大叫，她更倾向于哭泣。但那一刻，一股纯粹的怒火在她体内喷涌而出——愤怒和激愤交织在一起。
I was so pissed. Like, you know what? Like, I can't freaking believe this is how my day is going to go. Like, kick me while I'm down.
我当时气疯了。我就想，你知道吗？真不敢相信我今天会过成这样。这简直是往我伤口上撒盐。
Like, I was like, oh, hell, no, you are not going to ruin my day, sand. Like, I have fought for this lovely spring day. I am not going down.
我心想，哦，见鬼去吧，沙子，你别想毁了我这一天。为了这个可爱的春日，我付出了多少努力才来到这儿。我绝不会就这么认栽。
And with that burst of Hulk-like fury, she moves into action. She's like, quicksand? No problem. I will embrace the ridiculous awfulness of the situation, and I will make something happen right now. And she starts squirming around this way and that.
带着那种绿巨人般的狂怒，她开始行动了。她想：流沙？没门。我要直面这荒唐糟糕的境地，我要立刻扭转乾坤。于是她开始四处扭动。
I started to lean backwards. And at that point, when I leaned back, I was still sinking, but I was hoping that I could sort of just wiggle out of my boots and that my boots would be the sort of sacrificial lamb that I would just leave in the sand.
我开始向后仰。那一刻，当我向后仰时，虽然还在下陷，但我希望能借机把靴子蹭掉，让靴子成为我留在沙里的“牺牲品”。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
But I realized, if I just leaned back and kind of shimmied like a drunk person getting onto a bar stool, I could lift my legs out of the sand, little by little by little. The only sort of impediment was that my dog was looking at me like, this is a fun game. I just don't know how to play it. Like, she was just kind of darting around me, watching me move like this. So then I was getting really, really frustrated with her as well.
但我发现，如果我向后仰，像个醉汉跨上吧台高脚凳那样挪动，就能一点一点把腿从沙里拔出来。唯一的障碍就是我的狗，它看着我，以为这是一种好玩的游戏，只是不知道怎么玩。它就在我周围跑来跑去，看着我像这样扭动。所以我当时对它也感到非常非常恼火。
She wiggled her way out onto solid ground. At that point, she says, she's completely covered in sand-- wet sand in her hair, all over her clothes. She collects her dog, climbs in her car, drives home, cleans up. A week or two passes, and then one morning, she wakes up and realizes she feels OK.
她扭动着身体挣扎到了坚硬的地面上。那一刻，她说她整个人都被沙子覆盖了——头发里、衣服上全是湿沙子。她带上狗，爬进车里，开车回家，清洗干净。一两周过去了，有一天早上，她醒来时发现自己感觉好多了。
I remember so clearly, sitting in bed and saying to my husband, oh, my goodness. I think I'm good. I was filled with this content feeling that I can only describe as, like, the depression fading. Like, I didn't feel any of the heaviness. And I could only trace its disappearance to the quicksand.
我记得很清楚，当时坐在床上对丈夫说：噢，天哪，我觉得我好多了。我心中充满了一种满足感，我只能用“抑郁正在消散”来形容。那种沉重感消失了，而我只能将其归因于那次流沙经历。
Kendra thinks it has something to do with the anger she tapped into when she was stuck in the sand. As somebody who can't always express her anger, she thinks letting herself get so furious for once, it flipped something in her. That's the moment she was able to embrace just how bad things had gotten and fight her way out.
Kendra认为这与她在沙中受困时爆发的怒火有关。作为平时无法表达愤怒的人，她认为那一刻允许自己彻底愤怒一次，改变了什么。正是那一刻，她选择直面现状并奋力挣脱。
Today on our program, we have other stories of people put in difficult, sometimes impossible situations, and the only way out is to put their arms around the badness and feel it for what it is and then figure out some moves to wrestle the problem to the ground. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天节目里，我们还有其他关于人们身处困境、有时甚至是绝境的故事。唯一的出路是拥抱那份糟糕，正视它的本来面目，然后想办法将困境扳倒。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是伊拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Haley Mary Pass. It is the most magical week in American politics right now. Yes, it is. I'm speaking to you right now during the eight days between the Iowa caucus and the New Hampshire primary.
第一幕：黑莉·玛丽·帕斯。现在是美国政治中最神奇的一周。没错，确实如此。我是在爱荷华党团会议和新罕布什尔初选之间的八天里为您录制这段节目的。
The way it works-- the results in Iowa will reset the political scores and possibilities, redeal all the cards. And so this week that we are in right now can be an enchanted eight days where underdogs tell themselves that anything is possible, anything can happen, no matter how unlikely it is to, in fact, happen. And to witness this in person, one of our producers, Zoe Chace, went to New Hampshire this week to hang out with two people, two old friends who've chosen to embrace hope in the face of long and difficult odds.
运作方式是这样的——爱荷华州的结果将重置政治版图和可能性，重新洗牌。所以我们现在的这一周，是充满魔力的八天，失败者告诉自己任何事情都有可能发生，无论现实中发生的几率有多么渺茫。为了亲眼见证这一切，我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）本周去了新罕布什尔，和两位老友聚在一起，他们选择了在困难重重的局面下拥抱希望。
They know very well that Donald Trump will probably be the Republican nominee for president. And they are not happy about it. These guys are Democrats. But they are embracing the likelihood of Donald Trump's rise with a giant bear hug, and they are trying to do something about it.
他们很清楚唐纳德·特朗普很可能会成为共和党总统候选人。他们对此并不高兴。这些人是民主党人。但他们正以巨大的热情拥抱特朗普崛起的可能性，并试图为此做点什么。
And they are making a last stand to try to stop him this very week. And basically, what they're trying to do is they're trying to convince New Hampshire voters to get real about their options in this historic moment and vote not for who they actually want to be president, but vote for the only person these guys believe can stop Donald Trump from becoming the Republican nominee. And that person is Nikki Haley.
就在这一周，他们正在做最后的努力试图阻止他。基本上，他们的策略是试图说服新罕布什尔州的选民认清这个历史性时刻的选择，投票的对象不是他们真正想当总统的人，而是他们认为唯一能阻止特朗普成为共和党候选人的人。那个人就是尼基·黑莉（Nikki Haley）。
That's right. These two Democrats are stumping day and night to elect a woman who stands for so many things they personally hate. Zoe caught up with them one day before this enchanted week began-- that is a day before the Iowa caucus.
没错。这两个民主党人没日没夜地四处奔走，只为选出一个他们个人所厌恶的、代表着许多他们所反对理念的女性。佐伊在那个魔幻周开始的前一天，也就是爱荷华州党团会议的前一天，赶上了他们。
These guys aren't even from New Hampshire. They're policy wonks from out of state, outside agitators. One's from DC, and the other's from New York. They both work for do-goodery, international-interest-type places they prefer not to name on the radio. Robert Schwartz has been living in New Hampshire for three months.
这些人甚至不是新罕布什尔本地人。他们是来自州外的政策专家，也就是“外部煽动者”。一个来自华盛顿特区，另一个来自纽约。他们都为那些不愿在广播中透露名称的公益组织或国际利益相关机构工作。罗伯特·施瓦茨（Robert Schwartz）已经在新罕布什尔住了三个月。
He took a leave from his job, left his family, moved up here with his good friend Kenny-- Ken Scheffler, friends from college. I met up with them at a brewery in Keene, New Hampshire. And they're here this particular afternoon because a politician is on stage-- someone running in the Democratic primary, which is happening, even though Joe Biden decided to skip New Hampshire this year.
他向公司请了假，离开了家人，和好友肯尼——肯·谢弗勒（Ken Scheffler），也是大学同学，搬到了这里。我是在新罕布什尔州基恩（Keene）的一家啤酒厂见到他们的。他们今天下午出现在这里是因为有一位政客在台上演讲——一位正在参加民主党初选的人，尽管乔·拜登今年决定跳过新罕布什尔州。
The guy on stage, Congressman Dean Phillips, is making a random run for the presidency. But Robert and Ken are not paying attention to Dean Phillips. They're here for the 40 or 50 voters in the room. Robert is sort of irrepressible, says all his thoughts as he has them kind of thing, and starts whispering to me as soon as I get there.
台上的人是国会议员迪恩·菲利普斯（Dean Phillips），他正在进行一场随机的总统竞选尝试。但罗伯特和肯并没有关注迪恩·菲利普斯。他们是为房间里的四五十名选民来的。罗伯特是个自来熟，有什么想法就会直接说出来，我一到那里他就开始跟我耳语。
Because a lot of the people here, I think they-- a lot of people haven't really made up their mind yet. And so it's good for us to be here and just talk to them, because it is a lot of people that are undeclared voters.
因为我觉得这里很多人，很多人还没真正下定决心。所以我们在这里和他们交流很有意义，因为有很多人是未申报选民。
The way it works in New Hampshire, independent voters can vote in either primary-- Democrat or Republican. And there's a ton of people like that, something like 40% of the electorate. And this year, with Joe Biden skipping New Hampshire, Robert and Ken's mission is more plausible.
在新罕布什尔州的运作方式中，独立选民可以在两党的初选中投票——无论是民主党还是共和党。这类人非常多，大约占选民总数的40%。今年，随着乔·拜登跳过新罕布什尔州，罗伯特和肯的使命变得更加可行。
All these people who probably would have voted for Biden are free agents. Robert and Ken are here to pick off some of those people-- Democratic-leaning independent voters who might be willing to vote for Nikki Haley as a way to stop Trump.
这些原本可能投票给拜登的人现在成了自由人。罗伯特和肯来到这里是为了争取这些人——那些倾向于民主党的独立选民，他们或许愿意通过投票给尼基·黑莉来阻止特朗普。
I love you all.
我爱你们所有人。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
As soon as the event ends, Robert walks up to a random voter he doesn't know anything about, who's someone all bundled up in a blue parka, to see if he can convince her to cast a vote against everything she just heard on stage and throw in with the Republican primary instead. He has a very slow roll-up.
活动一结束，罗伯特就走向一位他完全不认识的选民，那人穿着蓝色大衣，看看能否说服她投出一张与她在台上听到的完全相反的票，转而投身于共和党初选。他的切入点非常缓慢。
Just what brings you-- I'm just curious, what brings you to this event?
只是好奇问问，是什么原因让你来参加这个活动？
Well, I want to see a change in the presidency. I don't like either one of them. Because Biden is too old, and I certainly don't want Donald Trump.
嗯，我想看到总统职位有所改变。这两个人我都不喜欢。因为拜登太老了，而我绝对不想要唐纳德·特朗普。
You don't. And are you a registered Democrat or undeclared?
你不想要。那你是有注册的民主党人还是未申报选民？
I'm independent, purposely.
我是独立派，故意的。
OK.
好。
Boom. He's found his target-- independent voter, leans to the left. You'd think he'd make his pitch. But he's learned this kind of voter doesn't like it when you open with a hard sell on Nikki Haley, because they don't like Nikki Haley, and he doesn't like Haley either. But he has to sell her on Haley, so it's kind of a weird conversation-- a lot of gymnastics.
太棒了。他找到了目标——左倾的独立选民。你可能以为他会立刻开始推销，但他已经学到，这种选民不喜欢你开门见山强推尼基·黑莉，因为他们不喜欢黑莉，而他自己也不喜欢。但他必须为了黑莉说服对方，所以这成了一场奇怪的谈话，费了不少唇舌。
So how are you thinking, like-- are you thinking you're definitely going to vote in the Democratic primary? Are you thinking about maybe voting against Trump in the Republican?
那你现在的想法是——你确定要在民主党初选中投票吗？还是在考虑也许要在共和党初选中投票反对特朗普？
I'm voting against Trump.
我是在投票反对特朗普。
Right. So have you thought-- even though Nikki Haley is a little bit-- like, she's got some rough positions on abortion and climate change and all that stuff, have you thought about voting for-- I'm not a Nikki Haley supporter. I'm a left-of-center person. But have you thought about--
没错。所以你有没有想过——即使尼基·黑莉有点……她在堕胎、气候变化等方面有一些强硬立场，但你有没有想过投票给……我不是尼基·黑莉的支持者。我是中间偏左的人。但你有没有想过——
Well, she was the next best candidate until I came here to listen to Dean.
嗯，在我来听迪恩演讲之前，她是下一个最好的候选人。
Oh, so--
噢，所以——
So I'm thinking more positively with Dean. Oh, yeah.
所以我对迪恩的想法更积极。噢，是的。
So I really like what Dean has to say. And I respect Dean. And if you don't like Biden, I get that that gives you an option. But what I think is--
所以我很喜欢迪恩说的话。我也尊重迪恩。如果你不喜欢拜登，我明白那给了你一个选择。但我认为的是——
I just feel he's just too old right now.
我只是觉得他现在太老了。
Right. But my thinking is, if you're concerned about the threat that Trump brings to our democracy, even though I like Dean more than I like Nikki Haley, like, I think she's a better vote, because he's asking you to damage Biden. And with a vote for Haley, you're damaging Trump.
没错。但我的想法是，如果你担心特朗普对我们民主构成的威胁，即使我比喜欢尼基·黑莉更喜欢迪恩，但我认为她是一张更好的选票，因为他（迪恩）在让你损害拜登的选情。而投给黑莉，你损害的是特朗普。
And so why vote-- if you're an undeclared voter and you hate Trump and think he's the biggest threat to the country, we need to get-- we need to embarrass Trump here. We need to show Trump losing, and--
所以为什么投给……如果你是一个未申报的选民，并且你讨厌特朗普，认为他是国家最大的威胁，我们需要让……我们需要让特朗普在这里尴尬。我们需要展现出特朗普输掉的局面，而且——
That's a very long hunter circling around some prey to kill. And you're not sure if he took a shot or not, but he thinks this is the best way to talk about Nikki Haley. He has this cautious approach, partially because of this thing people keep saying around here all the time. New Hampshire voters have to make up their own minds. Don't pressure me.
这就像是一个猎人绕着猎物转来转去想要击杀。你都不确定他是否开枪了，但他认为这是谈论尼基·黑莉的最佳方式。他采取这种谨慎的态度，部分是因为这里的人总是挂在嘴边的话。新罕布什尔州的选民必须自己做决定。别给我压力。
So it can be hard to tell how he's actually doing with this crowd, even though this woman says the most important thing to her is to stop Trump.
所以很难判断他在这群人中表现如何，尽管这位女士说她最重要的事情是阻止特朗普。
But you still don't know what the right path is.
但你还是不知道哪条路是正确的。
That's right. I don't know.
没错。我不知道。
My pitch would be, if you wanted--
我的说辞是，如果你想——
Our whole country feels that way. We just don't know.
我们整个国家都有这种感觉。我们只是不知道。
My pitch-- I mean, I come from Maryland. And it's your decision, not mine. But my pitch would be, if you want to stop Trump, you got to vote against the guy, even if it's for somebody you don't like.
我的说辞——我是指，我来自马里兰州。这是你的决定，不是我的。但我的建议是，如果你想阻止特朗普，你必须投票反对那个人，即使是为了一个你不喜欢的人。
I know.
我知道。
And with that, the voter has to go. We move on. This strategy-- getting people to hate-vote for Nikki Haley-- there's a word some people use for this kind of thing, a technical term in politics for sneaking around and doing dirty tricks inside the other party's election. Here's Ken.
说完，选民就必须离开了。我们继续前进。这种策略——让人们“含恨投票”给尼基·黑莉——有一种词汇来形容这类事情，政治上的专业术语是指潜入对方阵营进行肮脏把戏。这是肯的说法。
Someone tweeted that this is the most organized ratfucking operation of all time. Are you familiar with that term?
有人在推特上说这是有史以来最精密的“ ratfucking”（破坏对方阵营）行动。你熟悉这个术语吗？
Yes, I am. About you guys?
是的，我熟悉。是指你们这些人吗？
Yeah, yeah. But we don't see ourselves as ratfuckers.
是的，是的。但我们不把自己看作是这种破坏者。
Well, did you feel-- was it a compliment?
那么，你觉得这是一种赞美吗？
I believe it was a compliment, yeah. Yeah.
我相信这是一种赞美，是的。没错。
I think it is.
我想是的。
This whole quest of Robert and Ken's began one night last summer. They met up in DC and got onto the subject of how they think Trump is an existential threat to democracy, and can we get off the road to autocracy.
罗伯特和肯的整个探索始于去年夏天的一个晚上。他们在华盛顿会面，讨论到他们认为特朗普对民主构成存在威胁，以及我们是否能摆脱通往独裁的道路。
And Ken was like, you know, you have done stuff in the past to help other countries in this situation. Maybe we should actually do something.
肯当时说，你知道，你过去曾做过一些事情来帮助其他国家应对这种情况。也许我们真的应该做点什么。
Ken, I think, given his consulting background, was like, let's do a brainstorm, and this is how you do a brainstorm.
我想肯鉴于他的咨询背景，当时说，让我们来一次头脑风暴，这是进行头脑风暴的方法。
Yeah, Robert rolled his eyes.
是的，罗伯特翻了个白眼。
Yeah, well, can I tell her about your other idea that weekend? Ken has some really good ideas and some not so really good ideas. And so the other idea he tried to pitch me on that weekend was that the National Football League is too dangerous, and so we need to have--
是的，好吧，我能告诉她你那个周末的另一个想法吗？肯有一些很棒的想法，也有一些不那么棒的想法。所以他那个周末试图推销给我的另一个想法是，美国国家橄榄球联盟太危险了，所以我们需要——
We just lost half of America.
我们刚刚失去了美国的一半受众。
It's fine. So let's create a seven-on-seven football league that is more safe, and--
没关系。所以让我们创建一个更安全的七人制橄榄球联盟，并且——
Robert told him that was ridiculous. And here's the sort of person Ken is.
罗伯特告诉他那太荒谬了。这就是肯那种人。
And then he pulls out a PowerPoint showing his, like, idea for a seven-on-seven football league. And I was like, this is giving me serious doubts that we should proceed along this front. But he still actually believes it's a good idea.
然后他拿出了一个幻灯片，展示他关于七人制橄榄球联盟的想法。我就想，这让我严重怀疑我们是否应该继续下去。但他仍然真的认为这是一个好主意。
I do. I do.
我确实是这么认为的。
So anyway, after they got this idea for defeating Trump, they went out and raised money. And they say they raised $20,000 on their own, and then they got this big chunk of $650,000 from donors who wish to remain anonymous. And that's real money. That could have an impact on a small but mighty election like this one.
总之，在他们有了这个击败特朗普的想法后，他们就出去筹款了。他们说他们自己筹集了2万美元，然后从不愿透露姓名的捐赠者那里获得了一笔65万美元的巨款。那可是真金白银。这可能会对这样一场小型但重要的选举产生影响。
With that money, they bought targeted voter lists of undeclared left-leaning voters that they regularly message and send mailers out to-- mailers and messages that Ken has gotten focus-grouped and tested with professionals. They got a lucky break when Nikki Haley started to poll within 10 points of Donald Trump in New Hampshire. And so right at this moment, going into the Iowa caucus, their hope is she'd come in second in Iowa, that would give her the momentum to win New Hampshire outright, beat Trump, which would make her credible in South Carolina, and beyond that. They even hired two people in South Carolina, in case they have a shot there.
有了这笔钱，他们购买了有针对性的未申报左倾选民名单，并定期给他们发送信息和传单——这些传单和信息都是肯经过专业人员焦点小组测试的。当尼基·黑莉在新罕布什尔州的民调中开始落后特朗普不到10个百分点时，他们迎来了一个幸运的机会。所以就在这一刻，进入爱荷华州党团会议时，他们的希望是她在爱荷华州获得第二名，这将给她足够的势头直接赢得新罕布什尔州，击败特朗普，这将使她在南卡罗来纳州及之后更具信誉。他们甚至在南卡罗来纳州雇佣了两个人，以防他们在那里有胜算。
We always saw this as high risk, high reward. Like, if you looked at the polls, it has always looked like Trump will win the nomination. But if there's a 5% chance of stopping a potential dictator, it's worth putting a lot of effort into that.
我们一直将其视为高风险、高回报。就像如果你看民调，它看起来总是特朗普会赢得提名。但如果哪怕有5%的机会阻止潜在的独裁者，那么付出大量努力也是值得的。
Yeah, for that 5% chance that Haley shocks Trump here and there's an alternative in the-- like, it's worth it for our democracy.
是的，为了那5%的黑莉在新罕布什尔州震惊特朗普的机会，并且有一个替代方案……这对我们的民主来说是值得的。
Robert is really emotionally invested in this idea-- that maybe they, these two college friends, could actually do something to stop Donald Trump. He's intense about his work always, gets overly invested, it seems. At his day job, he was waking up having panic attacks about that work on top of this work. I was like, is this work helping?
罗伯特在情感上真正投入到了这个想法中——也许他们，这两个大学好友，真的能做点什么来阻止唐纳德·特朗普。他总是对工作充满热情，看起来投入过头了。在平时的日常工作中，他除了这份工作之外还在为那份工作经历惊恐发作。我当时想，这份工作有帮助吗？
No, this is not extremely healthy either. I tied myself into my career. And then rather than seek balance and view myself as a father and a brother and a son-- and instead of that, I have now identified myself as a part of this mission. And I'm wrapped up in that, and my whole self-worth is going to be determined on January 23, and that's not healthy at all.
不，这也不太健康。我把自己和职业挂钩了。然后我没有寻求平衡，把自己看作一个父亲、兄弟和儿子——相反，我现在把自己认定为这项使命的一部分。我陷入其中，我的整个自我价值都将取决于1月23日，这根本不健康。
So I'm really worried, from a mental health and all that perspective of, like, what happens after January 23 or what happens after the election in November. Like, at some point, there's going to be a reckoning, and I'm really afraid of that, to be honest.
所以我真的很担心，从心理健康等角度来看，1月23日之后或者11月大选之后会发生什么。老实说，在某个时刻，会有清算，我对此真的很害怕。
Robert's not alone, of course. They're not the only anti-Trump group trying to sway undeclared voters. And they're not big players, but they're real players. Still, they can go from sophisticated to bumbling very quickly, like when we found ourselves screeching around Manchester in a car on a way to an MLK Day celebration, late.
当然，罗伯特并不孤单。他们不是唯一试图影响未申报选民的反特朗普团体。他们不是大玩家，但他们是真正的参与者。不过，他们有时会从老练变得笨拙，就像当我们发现自己因为迟到，正坐车在曼彻斯特尖叫着赶往马丁·路德·金纪念活动的路上时。
As usual, they were glomming on to someone else's event, hoping to meet people who know more people who might carry their message out to other New Hampshirans. They volunteered to bring the coffee and the drinks. Their friend, Moises, was supposed to do it, but he's stuck at UPS printing up flyers with a QR code. The event has already started. Robert's freaking out.
像往常一样，他们想去蹭别人的活动，希望见到更多可能把他们的信息传递给其他新罕布什尔人的相关人士。他们自愿带了咖啡和饮料。他们的朋友莫伊塞斯本该这样做，但他被困在UPS打印印有二维码的传单。活动已经开始了。罗伯特急疯了。
So we're right by there. So we're going to stop there. You to get to the event and do damage control. Please. They're upset with us.
我们就在旁边。所以我们要在那里停下来。你赶紧去活动现场控制局面。拜托。他们对我们很生气。
OK.
好的。
Get to the event.
赶快去活动现场。
I'm trying. OK, bye.
我在尝试。好的，再见。
Bye.
再见。
Robert thinks of himself as responsible. And when he's not seen that way, it kills him.
罗伯特认为自己是一个有责任感的人。当他没有被这样看待时，这简直要了他的命。
Because we're going to be five minutes-- 10 minutes late to an MLK event. It's just embarrassing in some ways.
因为我们就要迟到5到10分钟参加马丁·路德·金活动。这在某种程度上太令人尴尬了。
How's your shame spiral?
你的“羞耻漩涡”还好吗？
Shame spiral is not in a good place right now.
羞耻漩涡现在情况不太好。
When they get there, Robert jumps out with three boxes of coffee, two huge bags of creamers. He's running around in the cold. Can't even find the door.
当他们到达那里时，罗伯特跳下车，带着三箱咖啡和两袋巨大的奶油。他在寒冷中跑来跑去。甚至找不到门在哪里。
Can you call Moises and ask how to get in the freaking building? Why don't they have signs? Thank you. Come on, Moises. Answer the phone. Did he not pick up? I'm just really frustrated.
你能打电话给莫伊塞斯问问怎么进入那座该死的建筑吗？为什么他们不放标识？谢谢。拜托，莫伊塞斯。接电话啊。他没接吗？我真的太沮丧了。
Once they're in, it's apologies and taping their QR code flyers onto Dunkin' Donuts boxes. And Robert works the line of people, tabling for various social justice-y causes, mostly white activists. New Hampshire is mostly white. Ken and Robert are white.
一旦他们进去了，就是道歉，然后把他们的二维码传单贴在Dunkin' Donuts盒子上。罗伯特在人群中穿梭，为各种社会正义事业摆摊，大部分是白人活动家。新罕布什尔州主要是白人。肯和罗伯特是白人。
And I get to witness just how tired people are of this kind of pitch. This is the third anybody-but-Trump election. You know what I mean? He talks with Deb Opramolla, who's Black.
我有幸见证了人们对这种推销方式有多么厌倦。这是第三次“除了特朗普之外任何人”的选举。你知道我的意思吗？他和黛布·奥普拉莫拉（Deb Opramolla）交谈，她是黑人。
Trump is not sophisticated enough to hide his white supremacy.
特朗普不够圆滑，无法掩饰他的白人至上主义。
Right, and Nikki Haley is more sophisticated at it.
没错，尼基·黑莉在这方面更圆滑。
And she's more-- and the sad thing is, she's a Brown woman--
而且她更……可悲的是，她是一个棕色人种的女性——
Right.
没错。
--lifting up white supremacy. So she's just a more sophisticated Trump.
——却在宣扬白人至上主义。所以她只是一个更圆滑的特朗普。
Well, but she also condemned-- she said January 6 was a terrible day, right? She doesn't call her military veterans suckers and losers. Like, would she launch a coup against our country?
嗯，但她也谴责了——她说1月6日是可怕的一天，对吧？她不会称退伍军人为傻子和失败者。她会发动政变反对我们的国家吗？
But she would pardon Trump.
但她会赦免特朗普。
Well, would you rather-- like, would you rather vote for the criminal or the one who pardons the criminal?
嗯，你愿意……你愿意投票给罪犯，还是愿意投票给赦免罪犯的人？
I would prefer not to vote for either.
我宁愿都不投票。
Well, right. I get that. But then who are-- you only have one vote in the primaries. And so the question is, like, where can you-- yes, you'd prefer not to vote for either, but then are you just throwing away your vote and letting Trump win?
嗯，没错。我明白。但既然——你在初选中只有一张选票。所以问题是，你在哪里可以……是的，你宁愿都不投，但你是不是在浪费你的选票，让特朗普赢？
I saw this move a few times from Robert, talking about people's vote like it was a commodity, like it was just a piece of currency that you could spend at this store or that store, and you just needed to squeeze the most value out of it that you could. That's a hard sell in New Hampshire. And he doesn't always seem so tuned in to how people might be thinking about their vote as theirs-- something between a personal statement and a moral obligation.
我几次看到罗伯特采取这种行动，谈论人们的选票就像商品一样，就像它只是你可以花在这家商店或那家商店的货币，而你只需要尽可能挤出它的最大价值。这在新罕布什尔州很难推销。而且他似乎并不总是那么清楚人们可能认为选票是属于他们自己的——介于个人声明和道德义务之间。
And here's the problem with what you're saying to me, is throwing away my vote--
这就是你对我说的话的问题所在，说我浪费选票——
Yeah.
是的。
--right-- is that Nikki Haley has yet, really, to address any Blacks. She has not gone out of her way.
——没错——是因为尼基·黑莉至今实际上还没接触过任何黑人。她没有刻意去做。
Yeah, that's true.
是的，那倒是真的。
And when the racism question came up in a very actually simple question to answer, she ran.
当种族问题出现在一个其实很简单回答的问题中时，她逃跑了。
She gave a horrible answer.
她给出了一个可怕的回答。
No, she ran. My vote is sacred. Am I going to spend it on her? No.
不，她逃跑了。我的选票是神圣的。我会把它花在她身上吗？不。
Well, there's one person who will tell you what they're doing-- or what they're not doing.
嗯，有一个人会告诉你他们正在做什么——或者他们没做什么。
The Iowa caucuses were that night, Monday. We watched early returns in a bar. Again, Robert was really rooting for Nikki Haley to come in second after Trump, turn the primaries into a two-person race. That's not what happened.
爱荷华州的党团会议是在那天晚上，星期一。我们在酒吧里看了早期的计票结果。罗伯特再次强烈希望尼基·黑莉能在特朗普之后获得第二名，将初选变成两个人的竞选。但事情并非如此。
She came in third, just behind DeSantis and well behind Trump. It's a huge setback, and Robert's upset. Things feel like they're starting to slip away, and he spends the rest of the night scrolling and angrily tweeting.
她获得了第三名，仅次于德桑蒂斯，落后于特朗普很多。这是一个巨大的挫折，罗伯特很沮丧。事情感觉正在开始失控，他花了一晚上的时间滚动手机并在推特上愤怒地发帖。
The next day, they have to regroup. The text messages they'd been planning to send to the 80,000 voters they're targeting were built around Nikki Haley doing better in Iowa. Now, they have to reframe things to make Iowa seem less important.
第二天，他们必须重组。他们计划发送给他们瞄准的8万名选民的短信是围绕尼基·黑莉在爱荷华州表现更好而构建的。现在，他们必须重新构思，让爱荷华州显得不那么重要。
Ken suggests a stock photo of a guy scratching his head with the words, "Does anyone actually know what a caucus is? New Hampshire picks presidents." Robert points out that he's butchering a famous New Hampshire saying, and they're both so stressed out, here's how that conversation goes down.
肯建议使用一张股票图片，上面是一个挠头的家伙，文字是：“真的有人知道党团会议是什么吗？新罕布什尔挑选总统。”罗伯特指出他正在糟蹋新罕布什尔州的一句名言，他们俩都压力很大，这是那次谈话的过程。
The line that everyone here recognizes, the political line that shows we're plugged into New Hampshire, is that line. "Iowa picks corn. New Hampshire picks presidents." That's the line--
每个人都认可的那句话，那句显示我们了解新罕布什尔州的政治名言，就是那句。“爱荷华州挑选玉米。新罕布什尔州挑选总统。”这就是那句话——
--New Hampshire picks presidents.
——新罕布什尔州挑选总统。
Yeah, but you're changing-- Iowa has a caucus. Who's ever heard of a caucus? It's not a good line. I'm sorry. I don't like it.
是的，但你正在改变——爱荷华州有一个党团会议。谁听说过党团会议？这不是一个好句子。很抱歉。我不喜欢它。
It's relatable.
它很贴切。
It's the famous line. It's John Sununu's line. There's a history of it. People recognize it.
那是名言。那是约翰·苏努努（John Sununu）的话。它有历史渊源。人们认得它。
Yeah, it's like a cliché here.
是的，这就像这里的陈词滥调。
Yeah, so?
是的，那又怎样？
It's not attention grabbing.
它不吸引注意力。
Ken, I'm the one that's been in New Hampshire for three months. I understand how the elites are viewing this. I'm telling you that's the line that people know. They don't want to say, what's a caucus.
肯，我是那个在新罕布什尔州待了三个月的人。我了解精英们是如何看待这个问题的。我告诉你，那是人们知道的那句话。他们不想说，什么是党团会议。
Give me credit for being here for three months and talking to every freaking person that I can. That's the line that people-- OK, I'm just saying, the first thing the guy said at the meeting today was that line.
给我一点信用吧，因为我在这里待了三个月，和每一个我能交谈的人交谈。那是人们——好的，我只是说，今天会议上那个人说的第一件事就是那句话。
OK.
好的。
Robert wins out. They go with the famous line and a photo of a cornfield that Robert insisted is provocative. He told Ken--
罗伯特赢了。他们采用了那句名言，并配上一张罗伯特坚持认为是挑衅性的玉米田照片。他告诉肯——
That's why I want to have the cornfields, but you don't want to have that. Like, it's edgy. It's insulting to Iowa.
这就是为什么我想用玉米田，但你不想。就像，它很前卫。它对爱荷华州是一种侮辱。
I met my last voters in New Hampshire later that day. Robert brought me to meet this couple in a lovely house on a snowy street in Manchester. He wanted to run the cornfield text messages by George Bruno, former Democratic Party chair.
那天晚些时候，我见到了我在新罕布什尔州的最后几位选民。罗伯特带我去曼彻斯特一条下雪的街道上的一栋可爱的房子里见这对夫妇。他想让前民主党主席乔治·布鲁诺（George Bruno）审阅玉米田的短信。
George had volunteered to be a public champion of Robert's cause, and Robert had managed to convince this august New Hampshiran to publicly change his party registration from Democrat to Undeclared. Only problem was, George still hadn't decided if he'll actually do the thing Robert was asking-- vote for Nikki Haley.
乔治自愿成为罗伯特事业的公众捍卫者，罗伯特设法说服了这位受人尊敬的新罕布什尔人公开将他的党籍从民主党改为未申报。唯一的问题是，乔治仍然没有决定他是否真的会做罗伯特要求的事——投票给尼基·黑莉。
I haven't decided.
我还没决定。
But it could-- even if--
但这可以——即使——
I think I made that clear. I am undeclared and undecided.
我想我已经说得很清楚了。我是未申报和未决定的。
I've been working on him for five months.
我一直在做他的思想工作，已经五个月了。
And it will become more clear as we get closer to February 23.
随着我们接近2月23日，它会变得更清晰。
No, January 23. Don't miss--
不，是1月23日。别弄错了——
Excuse me. January 23.
抱歉。1月23日。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I found this to be an ominous tale for Robert's quixotic mission, if George Bruno, this advocate for Robert's cause, couldn't even commit to doing the thing-- crossing parties, voting to save America in the Republican primary. But then, Robert turned to George's wife, Rona, who'd been in the kitchen while we'd been talking-- offering tea and reading The New York Times. She'd changed her party registration to undeclared, too.
我发现这对罗伯特的堂吉诃德式使命来说是一个不祥的预兆，如果乔治·布鲁诺这位罗伯特事业的倡导者甚至不能承诺做这件事——跨越党派，投票拯救美国在共和党初选中。但随后，罗伯特转向了乔治的妻子罗娜（Rona），我们在交谈时她一直在厨房里——提供茶水并阅读《纽约时报》。她也把党籍改成了未申报。
Robert asked her what she was thinking. She said she'd never vote for someone who didn't believe in reproductive rights. Robert said, even though Trump killed off Roe versus Wade? She said, well, that's a good point, actually.
罗伯特问她在想什么。她说她永远不会投票给一个不相信生殖权利的人。罗伯特说，即使特朗普废除了罗诉韦德案？她说，嗯，这确实是个好观点。
No, my original intent in crossing over was to assure that Trump would not become president.
不，我跨党派的初衷是确保特朗普不会成为总统。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Very near and dear to my values is the ability for women to control their own bodies and their reproductive rights. So it would be hard for me to cast a vote for somebody who might not respect that. On the other hand, the most important thing is to assure that he is not the candidate and not president.
女性控制自己身体和生殖权利的能力对我来说非常珍贵。所以投票给一个可能不尊重这一点的人对我来说很难。另一方面，最重要的事情是确保他不是候选人，也不是总统。
You're still--
你还在——
So I might have to compromise.
所以我可能不得不妥协。
Would you vote for Nikki Haley? She's the one that, according to the polls, looks the most likely to beat Trump.
你会投票给尼基·黑莉吗？她是民调显示最有可能击败特朗普的人。
Right. Recently, I read some of her stances, and she was really waffling on reproductive rights. So it scared me. On the other hand, I did this primarily to defeat Trump. So if it meant voting for her, I might do it. And I have a little more time to decide.
对。最近，我读了她的一些立场，她在生殖权利问题上真的很动摇。所以这吓到我了。另一方面，我做这件事主要是为了击败特朗普。所以如果这意味着投票给她，我可能会这样做。而且我还有一点时间可以决定。
Your face is just all screwed up.
你的表情纠结极了。
It's just because it's such an uncomfortable thought. But I want to defeat Trump. And if it takes voting for Nikki Haley to do that, I think I might do that.
只是因为这是一个如此不舒服的想法。但我想要击败特朗普。如果需要投票给尼基·黑莉才能做到这一点，我想我可能会那么做。
You know, I think she might really do it. When I left New Hampshire, it was halfway through America's magical eight-day period between Iowa's caucuses and New Hampshire's primaries. Robert seemed to swing from happily cherrypicking polls that told him what he wanted to hear to despair and real fear that they had no chance and Trump couldn't be stopped by anyone.
你知道，我觉得她可能真的能做到。当我离开新罕布什尔州时，正处于美国神奇的爱荷华州党团会议和新罕布什尔州初选之间八天期限的一半。罗伯特似乎在愉快地挑选告诉他想听到的民调结果，与绝望和真正的恐惧之间摇摆，因为他们没有机会，而且没人能阻止特朗普。
He told me he woke up crying on Thursday morning. This might all be over in a few days, he said-- the Alamo. Their project was a long shot from the start. They did their best. And now, since Trump's overwhelming win in Iowa, it'd gotten way long shottier. So was it worth it?
他告诉我他在周四早上醒来时哭了。这可能在几天内就全部结束了，他说——阿拉莫战役。他们的项目从一开始就是一次尝试。他们尽力了。现在，由于特朗普在爱荷华州的压倒性胜利，希望已经极其渺茫了。那么这值得吗？
If Trump wins by 15 or 20 points, I will view everything we've done as a failure. And I will consider myself a failure. And I know that's not-- like, we're doing everything we can, and it's not. And I need to be-- like, they tell you you have to be nicer to yourself and speak to you like a friend might speak to you.
如果特朗普以15或20个百分点的优势获胜，我将把我们所做的一切视为失败。我会认为自己是个失败者。我知道这不是——我们正在竭尽全力，并不是这样。我需要——他们告诉你要对自己更好一些，像朋友对自己说话那样对自己说话。
And a friend would say, nice try, good job, way to go, way to fight for it anyway. But I will look at-- like, I've made all these sacrifices on this gamble. And if the gamble turned out to be a wrong gamble and our country's not up to stopping Trump, then I made a huge miscalculation.
一个朋友会说，做得好，干得漂亮，无论如何都要战斗。但我会看——就像我在这次赌博中做出了所有这些牺牲。如果赌博结果证明是一个错误的赌博，我们的国家没有能力阻止特朗普，那么我做出了巨大的误判。
So that's Roberts anxiety. Here's Ken's.
这就是罗伯特的焦虑。这是肯的焦虑。
Do you feel like this is a referendum on yourself, too?
你觉得这也是对自己的一次公投吗？
I don't.
我不觉得。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No. I just really want Donald Trump to lose.
不。我只是非常希望唐纳德·特朗普输掉。
There are 343,192 undeclared voters in New Hampshire. Robert and Ken had just a few more days left to catch some of them, tell them to vote against everything they care about, and hold back, for just a little longer, what appears to be the inevitable course of history.
新罕布什尔州有343,192名未申报选民。罗伯特和肯只剩下几天时间来争取其中一些人，告诉他们投票反对他们关心的一切，并让看起来不可避免的历史进程再拖延一会儿。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show. Coming up, a baby gets in trouble with the law. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。接下来，一个婴儿惹上了法律麻烦。这将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续中揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show-- "Embrace The Suck." Apparently, that phrase started in the military and then moved into more general use, meaning you should just own how bad it is. Put your arms around it. Hold it close to you. That is the only way you're going to get through it.
这是《美国生活》。我是伊拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“拥抱糟糕”。显然，这个短语起源于军队，后来进入了更广泛的使用，意思是你应该接受现状是多么糟糕。拥抱它。紧紧抓住它。这是你度过难关的唯一途径。
Today, we have stories of people doing exactly that. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Dream Police. It's hard getting a baby to go to sleep. Everybody knows that. And different parents get through it different ways.
今天，我们讲述的人正是这样做的。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，梦想警察。让婴儿入睡很难。大家都知道。不同的父母有不同的方式度过这个难关。
Not long ago, one of our producers, Ike Sriskandarajah and his wife Emma were struggling with this with their son Leroy. At 1 and 1/2 years old, Leroy could say a few words, and he was actually able to hold an umbrella and crudely pull off a few of Gene Kelly's moves from Singing in the Rain while it played. I've seen video of this. He wasn't great, but he was amazing for somebody under 2 feet tall wearing a diaper.
不久前，我们的制作人艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾（Ike Sriskandarajah）和他的妻子艾玛（Emma）在儿子勒罗伊（Leroy）身上为此而挣扎。1岁半的时候，勒罗伊只会说几个词，他实际上能拿着雨伞，并在《雨中曲》播放时笨拙地跳出吉恩·凯利的一些舞步。我看过这段视频。他跳得并不好，但对于一个不到2英尺高穿着尿布的人来说，他很惊人。
Though I have to say, for all that accomplishment, Leroy was still not on a proper sleep schedule-- until his parents embraced the awfulness of the situation they were in and invented something. Here's Ike.
尽管我必须说，尽管有这些成就，勒罗伊仍然没有规律的睡眠时间——直到他的父母拥抱了他们所处的糟糕处境并发明了一些东西。这是艾克。
Leroy is the loudest guy I know. I'm pretty soft-spoken, so he didn't get that from me. One thing he did get-- we both really prefer to be awake. But Leroy takes it a little too far.
勒罗伊是我认识的最吵闹的家伙。我说话很温和，所以他没遗传到这一点。他确实遗传到的一点是——我们两个都更喜欢醒着。但勒罗伊太过分了。
When he was about one, I tried to put him down for a nap in his crib. He had bags under his eyes, his eyelids were heavy, and his head was doing that thing where it falls and snaps back. Then I saw him slap himself in the face to stay awake, like a long-haul trucker, fresh out of 5 Hour Energy.
他大约一岁时，我试图让他睡在婴儿床上。他眼下有黑眼圈，眼皮很重，头在点头又缩回。然后我看到他打自己的脸以保持清醒，就像一个刚喝完能量饮料的长途卡车司机。
And it's not just that he would fight sleep. When he did go to sleep, sometimes he'd wake up in absolute terror. But he needs to go to sleep. We all must. And we tried everything.
不仅仅是他会抗拒睡眠。当他真的睡着时，有时会从绝对的恐惧中醒来。但他需要睡觉。我们都需要。我们尝试了一切。
At five months, we tried sleep training. It didn't take. At one year, his soon-to-be daycare provider suggested the cry-it-out method, which, depending on what type of parent you are, is either the most efficient way to sleep train or the most barbaric. When they cry, it's your job not to comfort them. Don't go in, even if it sounds really bad, which it did.
在五个月大时，我们尝试了睡眠训练。没起作用。在一岁时，他即将入学的托儿所提供者建议了“让其哭泣”法，这取决于你是哪种类型的父母，要么是最有效的睡眠训练方式，要么是最野蛮的方式。当他们哭时，你的工作是不安慰他们。不要进去，即使听起来真的很糟糕，而情况确实如此。
We were a few weeks into this hellish ritual until one summer day. Leroy was looking sleepy, and it was time to attempt the 1:00 PM nap. I carried him to his room, drew the curtains, turned down the lullabies, gave him a fresh diaper, lowered him into his crib-- "Love you, Leroy, see you after your nap"-- and closed the door.
在这个地狱般的仪式持续了几周后，一个夏日。勒罗伊看起来很困，是时候尝试下午1点的午睡了。我把他抱到房间里，拉上窗帘，调低摇篮曲，给他换了新尿布，把他放进婴儿床——“爱你，勒罗伊，午睡后再见”——然后关上了门。
The crying started immediately, and I turned on a timer. For the next 40 minutes, Emma and I were clenched and approaching the upper threshold of our tolerance when she asked, "Can I pick him up?" "Yes, please." She went into his room, and then I heard our doorbell.
哭声立即开始了，我打开了计时器。在接下来的40分钟里，艾玛和我都紧绷着神经，接近我们的耐受极限，当时她问：“我可以抱他起来吗？”“是的，请。”她走进他的房间，然后我听到了门铃声。
I went to answer. And on the other side were two NYPD officers, a man and a woman. The woman asked, "Is that your baby crying?" "Yes." "We're responding to a child endangerment call."
我去开门。门外是两名纽约警察，一男一女。女警察问：“那个哭的婴儿是你的吗？”“是的。”“我们正在响应一个儿童伤害的报警电话。”
My mind was slowly grasping what was happening. Leroy, the loudest guy I know, had been screaming so much that a neighbor called the cops on us. They thought we were abusing Leroy. "We need to do a child welfare check," they said.
我的大脑慢慢理解了正在发生的事情。勒罗伊，我认识的最吵闹的人，哭得太厉害了，导致邻居报了警。他们以为我们在虐待勒罗伊。“我们需要进行一次儿童福利检查，”他们说。
I know these checks can turn into investigations. If you're poor, it can escalate fast. And even if you're not, it can be terrifying. Does Leroy have a scratch or a bruise right now? Are there piles of laundry lying around?
我知道这些检查可能演变成调查。如果你很穷，它可能迅速升级。即使你不穷，它也可能很可怕。勒罗伊现在有划痕或淤青吗？周围有没有堆积如山的脏衣服？
My adrenaline is pumping. And the voice in my head is telling me to say, fuck you, slam the door, and run with Leroy out the back. But don't listen to that voice. We don't have a back door.
我的肾上腺素在飙升。我头脑中的声音告诉我：去你的，砰地关上门，带着勒罗伊从后门跑。但不要听那个声音。我们没有后门。
I steadied myself. "You really don't need to do that. My wife, she's feeding him right now. He's busy." The male officer countered. "Either we go into his room or you bring him to us. We won't leave until we complete a visual inspection."
我稳住自己。“你们真的不需要这样做。我妻子，她正在喂他。他很忙。”男警察反驳。“要么我们进他的房间，要么你把他带给我们。在完成目视检查之前我们不会离开。”
"OK." I went to Leroy's room and told Emma, "The cops are here. They need to see Leroy." "But I'm breastfeeding." "I told them that." She brought Leroy to the door.
“好的。”我走到勒罗伊的房间告诉艾玛，“警察来了。他们需要看勒罗伊。”“但我正在母乳喂养。”“我告诉他们了。”她把勒罗伊带到了门口。
The woman officer asked, "Are you making all that noise?" Leroy was calm in Emma's arms. Emma said, "Sleep training. It's hard." The woman officer nodded. She gave him a little half baby wave and in a sweet voice said, "OK, you need to go to sleep."
女警察问：“那是你在制造所有这些噪音吗？”勒罗伊在艾玛怀里很冷静。艾玛说：“睡眠训练。很难。”女警察点头。她对他做了一个半婴儿式的挥手，用甜美的声音说：“好了，你需要去睡觉。”
Before they went, I asked, "Hey, just out of curiosity, can you tell me which neighbor called you guys?" "No." "Oh, OK. That makes sense." I started to hate all the neighbors who lived within earshot and didn't make eye contact.
在他们走之前，我问：“嘿，出于好奇，你能告诉我哪个邻居报的警吗？”“不能。”“哦，好吧。那说得通。”我开始讨厌所有住在耳边但不敢对视的邻居。
Our sleep-training experiment was over. We were back to laying on the floor next to his crib and trying to tiptoe out of his room when the coast was clear. Often, it was not.
我们的睡眠训练实验结束了。我们又回到睡在他的婴儿床旁边的地板上，试图在没人的时候悄悄溜出房间。通常，这做不到。
One night, Leroy passed the point of no return, crying whether I was there or not. And I got scared that the neighbor might call the cops again. Then I heard a police siren going past our apartment, and I thought, I can work with this.
一天晚上，勒罗伊过了无法挽回的界限，无论我在不在，他都在哭。我害怕邻居可能会再次报警。然后我听到警笛声经过我们的公寓，我想，我可以利用这一点。
"Did you hear that?" Leroy stopped crying and listened. "The policeman. He's driving by to check if you're going to sleep, and you're crying so loud, he can hear you."
“你听到了吗？”勒罗伊停止哭泣并听着。“警察。他开着车经过查看你是否要去睡觉，而你哭得太大声了，他能听到。”
Leroy asked, "What will he do?" Now, there are moments in life that feel like they define what kind of parent you are. Would I be the kind of morally bankrupt parent that scares my child to sleep?
勒罗伊问：“他会做什么？”现在，生活中有些时刻感觉定义了你是哪种父母。我会成为那种道德破产的父母，吓唬孩子睡觉吗？
I looked sweet Leroy in his big, beautiful, brown eyes and told him, "If the cops come back, they will take us away in different cars." He curled up under his blanket and closed his eyes tight. I left the room, shut the door behind me, held my breath, and waited.
我看着可爱的勒罗伊那双大而美丽的棕色眼睛，告诉他：“如果警察回来，他们会把我们带到不同的车里。”他蜷缩在毯子下，紧紧闭上眼睛。我离开房间，关上身后的门，屏住呼吸，等待着。
Silence. Incredible. It worked. And? Oh, god, what have I done? I reported the news to Emma. "Oh, no," she said. "He must be so scared."
安静。不可思议。它起作用了。然后？哦，天哪，我做了什么？我把消息告诉了艾玛。“噢，不，”她说。“他一定很害怕。”
"Do you think I should go tell him they aren't coming?" "I don't know." "OK. Well, let's never talk about this again." The next night, Leroy asked about the policeman. "Is he coming back?"
“你觉得我应该进去告诉他他们不会来吗？”“我不知道。”“好的。好吧，我们再也不要谈论这件事了。”第二天晚上，勒罗伊问起警察。“他会回来吗？”
I said, "Yes." And Leroy went to sleep. "Emma, I did it again." "Please don't tell me that." "Do you want me to stop?" "I don't know."
我说，“会。”然后勒罗伊去睡觉了。“艾玛，我又做了一次。”“请不要告诉我那个。”“你想让我停止吗？”“我不知道。”
I said, "Well, now, you're complicit." This became our new routine. Warm bath, cold milk. Emma would virtuosically perform all the voices in a stack of books. Then I would take Leroy to bed and threaten state violence. And we'd all go to sleep.
我说，“好吧，现在，你是共犯。”这成了我们的新常规。温水澡，冷牛奶。艾玛会艺术地演绎书中所有的声音。然后我会带勒罗伊上床并威胁国家暴力。然后我们都去睡觉了。
After a while, it stopped working. He got wise that the police weren't actually coming to our apartment every night, and he started crying again when I would leave. Now, I think it was Shakespeare who once wrote-- and I'm paraphrasing here-- when you find yourself halfway in a river of blood, either way you go, you've got to go through half a river of blood.
过了一会儿，它停止起作用了。他变得聪明了，知道警察并没有真的每晚来我们的公寓，当我要离开时他开始再次哭泣。现在，我认为曾经写下——我在这里转述——当你发现自己半身处在血河中，无论你往哪边走，你都必须穿过半条血河的人是莎士比亚。
So I forged ahead. One night when Leroy was crying, I closed the door behind me, took a deep breath, and banged on his bedroom door.
所以我继续前行。一天晚上，当勒罗伊哭泣时，我关上身后的门，深吸一口气，敲了敲他的卧室门。
[BANGING]
[敲门声]
"It's the police. Go to sleep." Just cancel me now. And yeah, it worked. We were living in an imaginary police state for what I'm sure child psychologists would agree was too long. Then one night, Leroy asked me a question I didn't see coming.
“是警察。去睡觉。”现在就把我取消吧。是的，它起作用了。我们住在一个想象中的警察国家里，我相信儿童心理学家会同意时间太长了。然后一天晚上，勒罗伊问了我一个我没预料到的问题。
"Will the policeman take my nightmares away?" Take his nightmares away? Not him? Somehow, in Leroy's cool, weird mind, he figured out that if the policeman was so scary, he could also scare whatever was haunting his dreams.
“警察会带走我的噩梦吗？”带走他的噩梦？不是他？不知何故，在勒罗伊酷酷又古怪的大脑里，他发现如果警察这么可怕，他也可以吓跑任何困扰他梦境的东西。
I was stunned. "Of course," I said. "He will take your nightmares. He'll put them in the back of his squad car and take them to jail." Leroy had taken his fear and morphed it into something that could protect him.
我惊呆了。“当然，”我说。“他会带走你的噩梦。他会把它们放进警车的后座，带它们去监狱。”勒罗伊把他的恐惧转化为可以保护他的东西。
I tried to teach Leroy how to sleep and pass along a healthy fear of the police. He learned neither. Leroy's three now. Our bedtime routine is less violent. I lay down next to him in his big-kid bed until he's asleep. The plan is to do this until he turns 18.
我试图教勒罗伊如何睡觉，并传达对警察的健康恐惧。他两者都没学会。勒罗伊现在三岁了。我们的睡前常规没那么暴力。我躺在他大儿童床旁边直到他睡着。计划是这样做直到他18岁。
OK. So what do we do at night?
好的。那么我们晚上做什么？
Take a soapy bath and put on your pajamas when you're done. Pee in the potty, lotion up, and read a book, and go to bed.
洗肥皂澡，穿上睡衣。在尿盆里小便，擦乳液，读一本书，上床睡觉。
That's it?
就这样？
Yeah.
是的。
That sounds easy. You just go to bed, no problem.
听起来很容易。你只是去睡觉，没问题。
We do all that stuff.
我们做所有那些事情。
Oh, you forgot one thing.
哦，你忘了一件事。
What?
什么？
You got to give a hug and a kiss.
你需要一个拥抱和一个吻。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hug. Hug.
是的，是的，是的。拥抱。拥抱。
OK. That's a lick.
好的。那是一次舔。
Ike Sriskandarajah is a producer on our show, currently on parental leave with a new baby who sleeps and wakes at will on his own schedule.
艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾是我们节目的制作人，目前正在休育儿假，带着一个随心所欲睡觉和醒来的新宝宝。
Act Three, Notes On Cycling. So we end today's show with one last story about things coming apart and somebody who just accepts it and, in fact, embraces it. This comes from Boen Wang, who made this story as a student for a podcasting class he was taking. He recorded his voice tracks into his iPhone.
第三幕，关于骑行的笔记。所以我们以最后一个关于事情分崩离析，并且有人只是接受甚至拥抱它的故事结束今天的节目。这来自博恩·王（Boen Wang），他制作这个故事是作为他正在上的播客课的学生作品。他把他的声音轨道录进他的iPhone里。
I have to say, I really loved Boen's work whenever I have heard it, because I feel like he is inventing a way to make radio stories that just have their own sort of feeling and sound. Anyway, here he is.
我必须说，无论我什么时候听到博恩的作品，我都很喜欢，因为我觉得他正在发明一种制作电台故事的方法，这些故事有它们自己独特的感觉和声音。总之，他在那里。
Don't worry. There's no point.
别担心。没什么意义。
[WINDOW OPENING]
[窗户打开声]
In the summer of 2015, I bought a bike from a guy on Craigslist. The bike was $40, so it was shitty. So it suited me.
2015年的夏天，我从Craigslist上的一名男子那里买了一辆自行车。自行车40美元，所以它很破烂。所以它很适合我。
I met the guy outside his house. A woman, who was possibly his wife, hung around and made occasional interjections, which he seemed experienced in ignoring. I asked if I could try the bike before I bought it.
我在他家外面见到了那个人。一个可能是他妻子的女人在旁边晃悠，并不时插嘴，他似乎很擅长忽视。我问在他买之前我是否可以试骑一下。
"Let's see the money first," he said. His words were kind of slurred, and his balance was kind of wobbly. His possible wife told him to cut me a break, which he ignored.
“先看看钱，”他说。他的话有点含糊，他的平衡有点摇晃。他可能的妻子告诉他让我通融一下，他没理会。
"I just don't want you getting any ideas," he said. So I gave him my backpack as a sort of security deposit, rode in a circle, got off, gave him the money, got my backpack, and rode away. It was downhill from there.
“我只是不想让你有什么想法，”他说。所以我把背包作为某种押金交给他，绕着圈骑，下来，把钱交给他，拿到背包，骑走了。从那以后就是下坡路。
[WINDOW CLOSING]
[窗户关闭声]
Like video games and birding and heroin, people who are into cycling are really into cycling. As for me, I wasn't into anything. I was living in State College, Pennsylvania, and attending Penn State. I lived off campus, so on weekdays, I rode to school, and on weekends, I rode around aimlessly.
像视频游戏、观鸟和海洛因一样，那些热衷于骑行的人真的很热衷于骑行。至于我，我不热衷于任何事情。我住在宾夕法尼亚州的州立学院，就读于宾夕法尼亚州立大学。我住在校外，所以平日里，我骑车去学校，周末，我漫无目的地骑车。
I was changing my major from engineering to English. But I still remembered that total mechanical energy is equal to the sum of kinetic and potential energy. Now that I had no use for this information, I realized that it's actually quite useful that you have to take into account how fast you're going as well as how much faster you can go.
我正在把专业从工程转为英语。但我仍然记得总机械能等于动能和势能的总和。现在我不再需要这些信息了，我意识到其实需要考虑你的速度以及你可以多快这是一个非常有用的知识。
[WIND BLOWING]
[风吹声]
The church I went to held monthly volunteer projects, usually at places far from campus. I never went before, because I didn't know anyone who would give me a ride. But now that I had a bike, I signed up.
我参加的教会举办每月的志愿者项目，通常在远离学校的地方。我以前从没去过，因为我不认识能载我一程的人。但现在我有了自行车，我就报了名。
One month, we painted a guy's house. His name was Tony, and he sat at the kitchen table and chain smoked as we painted the walls. During a break, I chatted with him. He told me he had bronchitis, and I avoided pointing out the obvious.
一个月，我们粉刷了一个人的房子。他的名字是托尼，我们粉刷墙壁时他坐在厨房桌旁抽着连环烟。休息期间，我和他聊天。他告诉我他有支气管炎，我避开了指出明显的这一点。
The next month, I cleaned out a dead woman's house. She had died of cancer. One of the volunteers there, Brian, said she lived alone and didn't have many friends. Her kids didn't call, so she would call Brian at midnight, and she wouldn't stop talking till 4:00 in the morning.
下个月，我清理了一个死去的女人的房子。她死于癌症。那里的志愿者之一，布莱恩，说她一个人住，没多少朋友。她的孩子不打电话，所以她会在午夜给布莱恩打电话，直到凌晨4点都不会停止说话。
He didn't seem too torn up about her death. Brian told me he did IT for Penn State. He went to school here in the '80s and stuck around for a few decades. He was her only friend, if you could call him that.
他看起来对她的死并不太难过。布莱恩告诉我他为宾夕法尼亚州立大学做IT。他80年代在这里上学，并坚持待了几十年。如果可以这样称呼他，他是她唯一的朋友。
[RECORD NEEDLE]
[唱针声]
[DIRTY BEACHES, "LORD KNOWS BEST"]
There's a video game called Gone Home, where you wander around your family's empty house. It's dark and thundering outside, and you go from room to room, turning on the lights and looking at different objects-- notes on the fridge, your sister's old journal, your mother's weekly salon receipt. The stuff is scattered about seemingly at random, but it's actually arranged in such a way so that a story emerges about the people who live there-- how your parents met and married and had kids and then drifted apart, how your dad may have been molested as a child, how your sister fell in love and ran away.
有一个叫《到家》（Gone Home）的视频游戏，你在里面徘徊在你家人的空房子里。外面又黑又雷，你一个房间一个房间地走，打开灯看着不同的物体——冰箱上的笔记、你姐姐的旧日记、你母亲每周的沙龙收据。东西似乎是随机散落的，但实际上是以一种故事随之出现的方式安排的——关于住在那里的人——你的父母如何相遇、结婚并生下孩子，然后疏远，你的父亲可能在小时候被骚扰过，你的姐姐如何坠入爱河并离家出走。
[MUSIC CUTS]
[音乐切断]
The women's house had no story, because life is not a story. Life is boxes filled with yellowed magazines, empty printers, broken CRTs, stereo sets, couches, mattresses, chairs, sheets, lamps, a mountain of material with no throughline. We started with the home office. It overlooked a dumpster in the driveway, so we threw stuff out the window.
那个女人的房子没有故事，因为生活不是一个故事。生活是装满泛黄杂志、空打印机、坏掉的显像管、立体声套装、沙发、床垫、椅子、床单、灯的盒子，是一堆没有主线的物质。我们从家庭办公室开始。它俯瞰着车道上的垃圾箱，所以我们从窗户把东西扔出去。
[WINDOW OPENING]
[窗户打开声]
A girl from Germany helped me defenestrate.
一个来自德国的女孩帮我抛窗。
[CRASH]
[撞击声]
She was a high schooler who, through some sort of exchange program, interned at the church.
她是一个通过某种交换项目在教会实习的高中生。
[CRASH]
[撞击声]
I asked her what sort of responsibilities a church intern had. And she either didn't understand the question or chose to ignore it, and I didn't press the issue.
我问她教会实习生有什么责任。她要么没听懂这个问题，要么选择了忽视它，我没有深究这个问题。
[CRASH]
[撞击声]
The hard part was the furniture. Brian and I tackled the heavy stuff-- the drawers and dressers and cabinets.
困难的部分是家具。布莱恩和我处理沉重的东西——抽屉、梳妆台和橱柜。
The dumpster was overflowing, so we had to break down the furniture before lifting it up and tipping it in. I felt a childlike satisfaction, turning the detritus of the stranger's life into ever-smaller bits of torn wood and popped nails. Towards the end of the day, Brian and I moved two redwood bookshelves onto the lawn. We'd thrown out the books beforehand. He brought hammers.
垃圾箱溢出来了，所以我们在提起并倾倒它之前不得不拆掉家具。我感到一种孩子般的满足，把那个陌生人生活中的碎片变成越来越小的木块和弹出的钉子。在一天结束时，布莱恩和我把两个红杉书架搬到了草坪上。我们事先扔掉了书。他带了锤子。
Instructions for smashing a redwood bookshelf on a dead woman's lawn. One, stand back. Hold the hammer at your hip. Two, move forward at a moderate speed, somewhere between walking and running.
在死去的女人的草坪上砸碎红杉书架的说明。一，站后退。将锤子握在臀部。二，以中等速度向前移动，介于步行和跑步之间。
(SUBJECT) TEXT-TO-SPEECH, BOEN WANG: Three, make a sweeping motion with your arm, lifting the hammer directly above your head. Four--
（主题）文本转语音，博恩·王：三，用你的手臂做一个挥舞动作，将锤子直接举过头顶。四——
Impact.
撞击。
[CICADAS]
[蝉鸣声]
(SUBJECT) TEXT-TO-SPEECH, BOEN WANG: Repeat steps one through four until complete. Ignore the church intern looking at you.
（主题）文本转语音，博恩·王：重复步骤一到四直到完成。忽视看着你的教会实习生。
At the end of the summer, I lost my best friend. "Lost" isn't the right word to use, as it implies passivity on my part. "Broke up" is closer, except that seems to only apply to romantic relationships. "Pushed away my best friend," "rejected her"-- something like that.
暑假结束时，我失去了最好的朋友。“失去”不是一个正确的词，因为它暗示了我的被动。“分手”更接近，除了那似乎只适用于浪漫关系。“推开了我最好的朋友”，“拒绝了她”——类似于那样。
I spent the summer biking to her apartment downtown. I told her about the chain smoker and the dead woman and the weird scent of loneliness in their houses. We cooked dinner, played board games, watched movies. We did the things we always did, except now I didn't want to do them.
我花了整个夏天骑车去她在市中心的公寓。我告诉她关于那个老烟民、那个死去的女人以及她们房子里孤独的怪味道。我们做饭、玩棋盘游戏、看电影。我们做了我们一直做的事情，除了现在我不想做了。
I told her that I didn't like spending time with her, that I didn't like her, that I didn't want to be her friend, that it wasn't her fault but mine, that I didn't understand it either, that I continued doing the things I did because I didn't know what else to do, and that, therefore, I should stop, and therefore we should stop being friends. It struck me even then as a pretty shitty explanation.
我告诉她我不想和她共度时光，我不想她，我不想成为她的朋友，这不是她的错而是我的，我也不理解，我继续做我所做的事情是因为我不知道还能做什么，因此，我应该停止，因此我们应该停止做朋友。即使当时我也觉得这是一个很烂的解释。
Most of this came out in a conversation we had walking back to the house I was living at. My bike, going tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, as I felt it twist in my chest, like I was hiding a terrible secret, except when I revealed it, my heart twisted tighter. A few days later, she sent me a 988-word Facebook message, an excerpt of which read--
这些大部分是在我们走回我住的房子时的谈话中出来的。我的自行车，发出嘀、嘀、嘀、嘀、嘀、嘀、嘀、嘀的声音，当我感觉到它在我胸口扭动时，就像我藏着一个可怕的秘密，除了当我揭露它时，我的心扭动得更紧。几天后，她给我发了一条988字的Facebook消息，其中一段写道——
If things are bad, can you just ask for a break instead of saying, "I don't want to be friends anymore"? And if you actually don't want to try anymore and you're certain want to let this go, then you can decide to break up. But it's literally the most hurtful thing you can do when you do that.
如果事情很糟糕，你可以只要求休息一下，而不是说，“我不想再做朋友了”吗？如果你真的不想再尝试，而且你确定想放手，那么你可以决定分手。但当你那样做时，这简直是你所能做的最伤人的事情。
So only do it when you've really truly decided that you want to let me go. And I will let go, which doesn't mean that I'll stop loving you or caring about you or praying for you. But in the end, I'll grow to be OK with not having you be a part of my life. You are more important than this relationship.
所以只有当你真正决定你想要放手时才那样做。我会放手，这并不意味着我会停止爱你或关心你或为你祈祷。但最后，我会习惯没有你成为我生活的一部分。你比这段关系更重要。
I sent her a two-word response. "OK. Sure." Before the school year started, I saw her one more time. She told me that I didn't mean what I was doing, that self-loathing was warping my thinking, that pushing her away seemed like the right thing to do now but wouldn't solve anything.
我发给她一个两个字的回复。“好的。当然。”学年开始前，我又见了一次她。她告诉我我不意味着我正在做的事情，自我厌恶正在扭曲我的思想，推开她看起来在当时是正确的做法，但不会解决任何问题。
In retrospect, it was my last chance.
回想起来，这是我最后的机会。
[STOPWATCH STARTING]
[秒表启动声]
She folded a piece of paper into a five-pointed star. She'd been in a church retreat the previous weekend and told me an illustration she heard about queer youths who come out in the church.
她把一张纸折成一颗五角星。她上个周末参加了一个教会静修，并告诉了我一个她听到的关于在教会中出柜的酷儿年轻人的插图。
When they start out, they have their family, friends, classmates, acquaintances, and the church. She pointed to a star's point for each category. When they come out in a conservative Christian setting, they usually lose their family first, she said, ripping off a piece of the star.
当他们开始时，他们有他们的家人、朋友、同学、熟人和教会。她指着星星的一个点代表每个类别。当他们在保守的基督教环境中出柜时，他们通常先失去他们的家人，她说，撕掉星星的一块。
She went through every category, tearing the star apart piece by piece, until all that was left was a jagged pentagon.
她走过每个类别，把星星一点一点撕掉，直到剩下的只有一个锯齿状的五角形。
[STOPWATCH STOPPING]
[秒表停止声]
I don't remember if I said anything. I left and didn't see her for a year.
我不记得我是否说了什么。我离开了，一年没见到她。
[RECORD NEEDLE]
[唱针声]
Let me tell you the point.
让我告诉你重点。
[FRANCOISE HARDY, "VOILA"]
[弗朗索瓦丝·哈迪, "VOILA"]
These days, the brakes on my bike don't work, so I scrape my foot against the ground to stop. When I lie in bed, I think of near misses I've had, cruising down a long hill and almost hurtling into traffic, pressing back with both feet in a desperate attempt to stop. This keeps me up at night, among other things.
这些天，我的自行车刹车不起作用，所以我用脚擦地停止。当我躺在床上时，我想起我经历过的惊险时刻，从长坡上滑下，差点冲进交通，用双脚绝望地向后按压试图停止。这让我晚上睡不着觉，除其他事情外。
The sole of my shoe is worn down, the rubber layers scraped away, and there's a smooth, gray surface beneath the hard, black sole. One of these days, I'll get the brakes fixed. But for now, I use my foot. Eventually, I stop.
我的鞋底磨损了，橡胶层磨掉了，在坚硬的黑色鞋底下方有一个光滑的灰色表面。这些天我会去修理刹车。但现在，我用我的脚。最终，我停下来。
Boen Wang-- he's a writer and audio producer in Pittsburgh. The other voice you heard during the story was Grace Gilbert. To hear more of Boen's work, visit his website, boen.cool. That's B-O-E-N, dot cool.
博恩·王——他是匹兹堡的作家和音频制作人。你在故事中听到的另一个声音是格蕾丝·吉尔伯特（Grace Gilbert）。要听到更多博恩的作品，请访问他的网站，boen.cool。那是B-O-E-N，点cool。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and Ike Sriskandarajah. Laura Starecheski was the editor. People who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Kyla Jones, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾制作。劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）是编辑。今天组装节目的人包括珍达伊·邦兹（Jendayi Bonds）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、伊曼纽尔·佐特西（Emmanuel Dzotsi）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、萨菲亚·里德尔（Safiyah Riddle）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、弗朗西丝·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、凯拉·琼斯（Kyla Jones）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. This is our last show with our fellow, James Bennett the Second.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。这是我们和我们的研究员詹姆斯·本内特二世（James Bennett the Second）的最后一场节目。
He is off to a job as one of the hosts of a podcast and radio show at GBH Boston called The Culture Show. We all wish him the best. Special thanks today to Isaac Arnsdorf, James Pindell, Michael Graham, Katherine Dunn, and David Barbeau.
他去GBH波士顿一个叫《文化秀》（The Culture Show）的播客和电台节目担任主持人之一。我们祝他一切顺利。今天特别感谢艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫（Isaac Arnsdorf）、詹姆斯·平德尔（James Pindell）、迈克尔·格雷厄姆（Michael Graham）、凯瑟琳·邓恩（Katherine Dunn）和戴维·巴博（David Barbeau）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's the king of boggle. There is none higher.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过800集的档案。 《美国生活》由公共无线电交易所（PRX）分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。他是Boggle之王。没有比这更高的了。
But he hates that little hourglass thingy. When the time starts running out, he always says--
但他讨厌那个小沙漏。当时间快用完时，他总是说——
Oh, hell, no, you are not going to ruin my day, sand.
哦，见鬼去吧，沙子，你别想毁了我这一天。
Did I mention how many points he got for "quagmire"? I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我提过他因为“quagmire”得了多少分吗？我是伊拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。